it should be just as alarming if not
equally so as the fact that all these
people are dying suddenly that people
don't want to even let you do what you
described right look into patterns look
into consistencies and it literally goes
just to the shirt that you're wearing if
it's it's not science if you can't
question it it's propaganda and so
genuinely like why is there such a
resistance for people just to know the
truth to know if there is a pattern if
there isn't that's okay we're okay with
being disproven we're not actually even
making the assertion there's nothing to
disprove we just want facts we want
truth but also too there's just seems to
be like so much resistance to it which I
think should concern everyone like why
would you even ban a documentary like
died suddenly from the internet if there
wasn't something there I don't know well
the censorship you know it's it's the
Game of Thrones quote from Tyrion
Lannister when you cut on cut out a
Man's Tongue you don't prove him wrong
you only prove you fear what he has to
say